[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hi.
I'm Richard Hyndman, an engineer
on the Android
Developer Relations team.
With the launch of Android
Jellybean 4.3, we've seen some
great new features for users and
developers alike, and I'm
going to run you through
restricted profiles.
In Jellybean, we announced
multiple users so you could
share your tablet easily with
your family members.
Everyone would create their
own profile, sign in with
their own Google accounts,
install their apps, and just
use it as if it was
their own tablet.
But if you were sharing your
tablet with a child, this
sometimes got a little
bit complicated.
You'd probably create them a
profile, but then sign in with
your own Google account, install
some apps, maybe put a
PIN code on the Play store,
change the synchronization
settings, maybe disable some
apps-- just really try and
make it a restricted,
safe environment for
that child to use.
With restricted profiles, this
has become a whole lot easier.
Restricted profiles are based on
the primary user's profile.
They share the Google account
and the applications of that
primary user, but in a
restricted manner.
The restricted users don't
get access to your Gmail,
Calendar, Play Store,
or in-app purchases.
The primary user can choose
which apps they can access,
and whether those
apps can access
things like device location.
As a developer, the Restricted
Profile API allows you to
offer up fine-grain control over
your application and your
application's restrictions.
And the user manager has also
been extended so your
application can find out
what restrictions are
being imposed on it.
Application restrictions
are managed under
the Device User Settings.
So when you create a new
restricted profile, you'll see
a list of all the applications,
and you can
choose which ones
are available.
And your application
will automatically
appear in this list.
But if you have specific
settings, you're going to want
to let the platform
know about them.
So how do you do that?
You add the intent-filter into
Android Manifest for the
GET_RESTRICTION_ENTRIES.
This is going to prepare Android
to add that Settings
button in the Settings
screen like this.
So here we've got the
Settings button.
And when you press it, it's
going to populate with your
restrictions.
Here we've got some example
restrictions,
Full Restriction Enabled.
In this particular app, you can
choose whether or not the
child user, the restricted user,
can change the language
or access any in-app items.
So to populate these settings,
the system is going to
broadcast the action
GetRestrictions intent to your
application.
And it's going to expect that
you return with an array list
of restriction entries
in the bundle.
So in the broadcast receiver,
when you get the broadcast,
the first thing you want to
do is call goAsync on the
broadcast receiver.
This is going to keep it active,
and also give you a
PendingResult object to return
your restrictions in.
Then you create an array list of
restriction entries and put
it in the bundle
and return it.
We've got three different types
of restriction entry.
We have the Boolean type,
just on and off.
We've got the check box, single
select from a list, and
we have multiple selection
from a list.
Three different types.
And looking at those in code,
we have three different
constructors for those
different types
of restriction entry.
And all of those constructions
take a key so that later on
you can retrieve the setting
from the system, and also a
default, or current value.
Here we've got the Boolean
type, and then the single
choice type.
Maybe in the single choice type,
you want to use it for
content rating of the
content available to
a restricted user.
So you could have single
choice of under
12, 15 plus, whatever.
And then you could just choose
one of those and make the
content in your application
relevant for the user.
And then the multiple choice
type is going to take an array
list of strings for
the default.
So now, the system's asked you
for your restrictions.
You've returned them in this
bundle, an array list of
restriction entries.
And then the device owner has
been and set the exact
restrictions for their child.
So the final step, of course,
is going to be to retrieve
those restrictions
from the system.
So onResume in your application,
you can recall
the restriction set by getting
hold of the system service for
user service, and then get the
application restrictions for
your package.
Of course, this may come
back without any
restrictions in it.
In that case, you'll be running
in the device owner's,
or an unrestricted profile.
But if you're in a restricted
profile, you'll see all the
restrictions.
You can collect them back from
the keys that you specified
earlier and find out the
settings that there are.
If you don't want any specific
settings, but you just want to
find out if you're in a
restricted profile at the
moment, you can call
GetUserRestrictions and just
check if that bundle
is empty or not.
If it's empty, you're
not restricted.
And if it's not, you're
almost certainly in
a restricted profile.
So that's how restricted
profile works.
But there is, of course,
just one more thing.
If you'd rather have your own
nice, tidy UI inside your
application, a single place to
manage all your restrictions
that when the device owner is
running your app, they can see
it, and then when they go
through settings and press it,
it launches your activity
instead of showing the
settings directly in the
Settings screen, you can have
custom restrictions.
So when the
GET_RESTRICTION_ENTRIES
broadcast is broadcast out to
your app, instead of returning
an array list of restriction
entries, you can return an
intent to launch your
custom activity.
This is similar to the way it
works for battery users, data
users, things like this, where
you can launch an intent into
your application to show
you around the screen.
So that should be all
you need to know
about restricted profiles.
They're especially useful for
content-based applications,
and I'm looking forward
to seeing what use
cases you come up with.
Thank you very much.